Our NDP government is following through on our commitment.
Free birth control will be available in Manitoba
beginning on October 1st.
Our government will cover the prescription birth control costs
for pills, IUDs,
injections for anyone who has a prescription from a doctor
or another healthcare provider.
We know that over a lifetime,
birth control can cost thousands of dollars.
This announcement today is about reproductive justice.
Free birth control gives women,
girls and gender diverse folks freedom,
the freedom to determine their paths that their lives take
and the opportunity to live their best lives.
And in a world where reproductive rights are increasingly threatened,
our government's announcement today affirms reproductive healthcare
as a human right
and as a means of empowerment and liberation for Manitoba women,
girls and gender diverse folks.
Today and always,
our government continues to affirm the reproductive rights of women
and all Manitobans.
Today's announcement will ensure that all Manitobans in need
will have access to reliable contraception
and secures their ability to make a reproductive life plan.
And it further empowers women to make decisions around their education
and careers that are solely based on their own hopes and dreams
and not around unintended pregnancies.